scams targeting senior citizens are
increasingly are increasing dramatically
the Department of Justice says an
estimated three billion dollars are
stolen from millions of seniors a year
yesterday the DOJ announced its largest
fraud crackdown of its type in history
Paula Reed is outside the Department of
Justice she spoke to victims about how
to protect yourself and your family
Paula good morning good morning
law enforcement officials tell me that
scammers specifically target the elderly
because they're thought to have large
savings and also thought to be from a
more trusting generation they also tell
me that these scams are becoming
increasingly clever and sophisticated
and that anyone can become a victim I
felt like the bottom had dropped out you
know all the hope we had was gone a
scammer called Dorothy Lam being of
Louisiana saying she had won a prize
worth thousands of dollars all she had
to do was purchase a six month supply of
vitamins the call came at a desperate
time as she and her husband were
battling cancer
I checked with a Better Business Bureau
and he was not listed with any
complaints and so I said well okay it
might be something true she gave the
scammer two thousand five hundred
dollars Dorothy is one of millions of
older Americans targeted by scammers the
Justice Department says fraudsters reach
out with calls emails or regular mail
promising cash valuable prizes or good
fortune if the recipient sends back a
payment for processing fees such as this
mailing scheme by one network of
scammers according to court records they
mailed more than nine hundred and fifty
thousand fraudulent solicitations to 38
states like this one promising a three
point three million dollar prize it says
a day you may remember for the rest of
your life tell nobody since 2011 victims
paid this network of scammers
approximately ten million dollars on
Thursday attorney general Jeff sessions
announced criminal charges against over
200 scammers who mostly target the
elderly these defendants allegedly
robbed the fraud in more than one
Americans more than half a billion
dollars he wants people to know there is
help the FTC has a hotline and a website
we literally found out ten days before
she died that this was happening to her
Angela staunch Xpand mother Marjorie
committed suicide with just 69 dollars
in her bank account after investing her
money in a scam we're still shocked that
this happened to her she wishes her
grandmother had reached out to her
family sooner and urges others who may
be caught up in a scam not to be ashamed
to ask for help there's someone who can
help you and and if you don't feel like
it's your family then call your local
police department she urges family
members to monitor elderly relatives to
help protect them from financial
predators watch what they're doing
watch how they're spending their money
check their phones check check their
mail
Dorothy's money is gone but she hopes
her story will help other victims come
forward we got to stop these people from
hurting other people and it hurts so
much it hurts more than people know
another way that elderly folks are
exploited Arthur's so-called grandparent
schemes where someone calls and tries to
convince them that their grandchild has
been arrested and needs money for bail
in fact the Attorney General says he was
in a meeting with one of his young
staffers when she received a frantic
call from her grandmother who thought
she was in jail the FBI says before you
send money to anyone you don't know to
check with law enforcement first Fiona
unbelievable our hearts go out to
Dorothy important reporting Paula thank
you